breaking news shell one of the world's
largest oil and gas companies is getting
into Bitcoin mining what am I talking
about it just came out that shell has
entered into a two-year deal to sponsor
the Bitcoin conference in 2023 and 2024.
why are they doing this well shell now
wants to work with all of the Bitcoin
miners around immersion cooling what
does that mean if you ever have been
inside of one of these data centers
where they are mining Bitcoin there are
two ways that you can cool the machines
to keep them running efficiently the
first is that you can use airflow either
naturally in a cold environment or you
can blow in air-conditioned air the
other way is that you can actually
immerse the machine in some sort of
liquid cooling that keeps it efficiently
run shell has a lubricant Division and
that is what they are trying to do they
want to get into the immersion cooling
game which would help Bitcoin miners run
more efficiently help secure the Bitcoin
Network and ultimately grow Global hash
rate it is awesome to see the great
folks over at Bitcoin magazine and the
Bitcoin conference partnering up with
shell who hopes to bring this great
technology to Bitcoin mining as we have
talked about over and over and over
again every single large oil and gas
company is going to get into Bitcoin
mining it is a profitable use of both
their oil and also natural gas we've
seen things like gas flare capture but
we also see many pilot projects across
the industry to see shell one of the
most recognizable brands in the industry
start to openly talk about what they are
doing in Bitcoin mining is a bullish
signal that should drive lots of
interest from their colleagues and
competitors on top of that having them
talk at the Bitcoin conference will be a
very big deal and to see them putting
Capital into something like the Bitcoin
conference is a very good sign congrats
to the people at Bitcoin magazine to the
folks over at the Bitcoin conference and
shell welcome to the game in the public
Arena it'll be awesome to see what you
guys accomplish and how you can help
Bitcoin miners continue to push this
great asset forward